guarda tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
va bene io sono quello che fai video e
siano su ultra adhd va bene iniziamo con
l'ultra adhd e vediamo c'è uno che fuma
giorno in questo e quando mi sveglio la
mattina e non mick non so dove sono
ancora ecco questo mi succede tronto
hanno risposto al telefono per questo lo
vedo voce femminile a buono a devo
mettere il mio nome
fabrizio soft fabrizio a franklin
partito dei fan david è il mio nome è
fabrizio che c'è qualche problema
parlando col padre naturale si è
intromesso in tutto questo possiamo dare
avanti che cosa me ne frega di che mi
chiamo fabrizio perché non rispondi a
niente di quello che stiamo dicendo
perché fate schifo basta magagna allora
si caricano sul gioco per continuare a
leggere
ok perfetto cosa col quale scusa della
ripresa attenzione a causa della fine
dei tempi l'entrata la foresta è
strettamente proibita
ok buongiorno la fine dei tempi incombe
va bene la profezia ci dice che un
errore silente sconfiggerà il male
salverà il mondo
preghiamo il nostro dio e salvatore per
la salvezza potresti essere tu guarda io
ancora non so cosa vangelo pranzo quindi
per me c ran nella fine del mondo scalve
e john come ora bisogna fare qua c'è un
morto si è sparato ce n'è un altro e tu
suoni
questa è la fine va bene
in tutto questo vorrei della banca usa
un canto www.flog.it
bwv allontanati da me se vuoi continua a
respirare www figlio di puglia va bene
salve
vabbè è morto fa niente mi dispiace ma
lo store è chiuso per la fine dei tempi
fabrizio ha chiesto fabrizio tutto
questo chi se ne frega io vorrei
riuscire a cio un'arma adesso la quindi
io posso posso picchiare la gente adesso
non posso picchiare le big foot
motherfucker non mi ha pagato quindi va
cos'è che vuoi soldato alt l'entrata
nella pro la foresta e strettamente
proibita per il numero di zombie
nell'area ma aspetta mi sembri
famigliare farmi controllare qua
comunque ti farò passare perché mi
fabrizio va bene basta parlare basta
autore di parla di dialogo
anyway entriamo nella foresta anche se
fa niente ho dato che arma è questa se
non fiammifero ma che deve fare fuori di
zombie non vedo l'ora
shift touran padre natura va bene
madre natura vuol dire fater band made
aspetto che controllo per cure si trovi
magari fatto una gaffe incredibile non
vuol dire patria non so se fate chiamano
fatherland enpals all'asino faccio gas
persona suicida ma come quanto contento
tra quanto contento o sono zombie
ho vinto io pezzente a perfetto non sono
anche chi arma sia questa prova
chi se ne frega un bel sobis e di gioco
più bello del loro colgono il momento il
tasto falli in acciao perfetto questo
cos'è ho preso dei gol
bruxelles vabbè
mira fuoco reload tra pistola
va bene mira fuoco reload mila fuoco
reload ci sono mira a fuoco reload però
non ho nemici o solo gente impiccata
felicemente è ma c'è una gittata fa
cagare star ma è sicuramente meglio di
quella di prima perfetto buongiorno
madonna della bici camminare o cacchio o
finiti i colpi aiuto la micron e si
carica ma e penso che i colpi non siano
infiniti a questo punto maledizione non
so come si aiuto poiché si carica di
meno a chi cerchiamo anche perfetto non
ho hanno quindi questo gioco non son
riusciti a fare le grafiche decenti
perché va beh mi sembra proprio il
compenso solo ischia mettere in
proiettili va bene ei fabrizio lui a
fornire a eccovi a devi far fuori di
zombie prima di venire ok faccio io
madre alla fine padre natura sono dice
padre patrick tutti quanti devo far
fuori e che non ce ne sono più
teoricamente forse
praga c'è la nebbia se silent hill ce
n'è uno qua faccio fuori questo arrivo
finisco la peperonata e scendo adatto
sono mi hanno fatto malissimo
quindi devo di recuperare vita
solitamente ho dato colpi evolveranno
carica che si carica a posto
ragazzi ho un proiettile voi che siete
che dirigente fate le cose wonder fuori
ora ride
chissenefrega fabrizio è brava di cago
perché tanto sono state due la palla
dalla stessa cosa non c'è un soldato che
bello
basta ok diamanti 2 ottobre corte
suprema card causa number one che è
successo tutto sto casino per non ho
capito cosa sta succedendo non ho capito
quindi dove era un gioco tutto tutto
facciamo finta che non avete visto
niente di tutto ciò andiamo avanti
questo invece è crumble è un gioco che
si fa col joystick play demo ci abbiamo
giocato alla alla beta della beta della
beta
questa è la beta un po meno teoricamente
credo o mio dio crumble bisogna fare un
santo dio a devo sopra atwood amp per
questo l'ha voluta toe devo andare
avanti così
io mi ricordavo che dovevi a un certo
punto sopravvivere perché tentavano di
buttarti giù tutto quello in cui eri
cioè praticamente tu non si sono
ricordate l'avevo fatto sto gioco che è
migliorato tantissimo in un punto dove
devi tentare di sopravvivere e loro
tentavano di buttarti giù nel mentre non
lo so se ora cavalca pescando bellissimo
non so perché mi sto rilassando un sacco
ragazzi ho finalmente siamo passati
dallo sparare zombie brutti a questo c'è
poi bello che mi metto in check point
come se fosse possibile morire 4 ma che
ho detto sta cagata morirò subito porco
demonio ecco l'ho detto madonna sono
vivi per un miracolo a posto a posto
porca vacca su cascato perfetto
porca vacca cosa ho visto bellissimo
rischiato tantissimo dall'altro però
sono sopravvissuto non si sa come mi
sono preso in tempo
miracolo a posto riprendiamo del karoo
madonna ecco eccoci
ecco questa è la parte 2 milan chavannes
addosso le cose perfetto ma ricordo che
dove tenta di sopravvivere in questo
posto prima che crollasse tutto noi
mentre mi sparavano vediamo se è rimasta
e che lo sapevo vedi sta partita rimasta
porca vacca ci provo
gli oro con le app tutto perfetto
el obiettivo era rimanere il più tempo
possibile vivo adesso non è più così ma
raggiungere l'astronave a quanto pare no
nostro amato marco demonio è
difficilissimo ma se mi saltò tutto il
livello volevo fare il furbo ma non ci
sono riuscito si chiude vi sembra facile
ma vi giuro
no vabbè incredibile e dunque così ti
sparano addosso non è per niente
semplice
molto bene
madonna raga incredibile ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta eccoci
eccomi o mio dio
sei ore per quale del completa le vele
perché fatta livelli madonna ma
veramente no no vabbè suo male aiuto e
devono tendere cedevo devo fare cosa
devo fare
occhio madonna come ho rischiato sono
caduto non mi sono salvato perché mi
sono aggrappato alla la mio dio
vabbè svolgeva il preso un check point
lo pregio si prova è stata un'ora
aggrappato ok ma il penalty mattinata in
atto in al tema fiat e ragazzi hanno
fatto reale c'è insomma è un concept di
gioco pazzesco è veramente difficile ce
la vedo vedo la mia astronave in
lontananza quindi c'è speranza se non
vado contro st roccia perfetto c'è più
speranza scherzavo
non è che non vedo io gli aerei di linea
porco demonio sono tornato sul proprio è
possibile come ho fatto sta provata sono
tornato sopra dopo che ero caduto oddio
bora bora bora bora bravo lo zio occhio
che qua colpisci colpisci quel
gravissimo madonna che mi sono salvato
forse ci arrivò pure forse ci arrivò
pure forse suo arrivo pure mi si è
schiantato l'aereo in tutto questo ma io
sono salvo incredibile belliche gioco
pazzesco pazzesco sono tre livelli si
vero perché non visti altri nel punto
dura
2 c ma no cioè non solo a port kakà
nascosti tra peccato
perché veramente figo peccato perché
ovviamente perché è una demo ragazzi
sono sono durerebbe di non vedere che il
gioco ufficiale perché veramente
fighissimo comunque spero che vi sia
piaciuto iscrive telechiara le spiagge
del tasto mi piace e ricordatevi che
finché non guido io ieri siamo a posto
e noi ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
vitobello ragazzi
[Musica]